breaking news inflation in the united
states just came in at 8.6 percent this
is the highest it's been over 40 years
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
just doesn't work of course there's a
huge problem many economists and market
analysts they thought inflation had
peaked back in march we saw 8.3
inflation in april and they expected the
may number to be low as well but as we
saw inflation has only accelerated it's
getting worse 8.6
is the highest in 40 years now of course
inflation is made up of many many
different numbers and if we take a look
one of the most concerning ones is that
food at home the cost to eat food in
your own home is now up 11.9
over the last 12 months gasoline is up
nearly 50 percent as well this is
completely unsustainable for the average
american family but these numbers don't
tell the full picture if we actually
take a look gabor here pointing out that
over the last 18 months the average u.s
retail gas price has more than doubled
that spells absolute chaos for an
average american family food is up
double digits gasoline is up double
digits and of course as we look at these
numbers these are only the official ones
if the official numbers are positioning
it at 8.6 percent the real inflation
rate is likely in the double digits now
as you go back and look the last time
that inflation was this high in 1980 and
1981 what we saw was a change to the cpi
calculation and methodology instead of
actually fixing the inflation pump they
just changed the way that the
methodology was calculated and so if we
take a look at other methodologies today
we can see that those other calculations
have inflation coming in much much
higher take something like true flation
trufflation is showing inflation at
10.75 percent they are trying to more
accurately measure it you can believe
the official numbers or you can believe
something like true inflation but either
way inflation is high in america and
it's not going down and so here's the
big problem is that not only or is the
cost of goods and services increasing
but at the same exact time wages are not
keeping up if we take a look at
inflation-adjusted average hourly
earnings over the last 12 months it's
negative literally people are getting
paid less money than they were just a
year ago if the cost of goods are rising
and wages aren't keeping up that spells
big big trouble naturally what we have
to be saying to ourselves is where is
the relief going to come from the
average american family cannot withstand
this type of economic chaos uncertainty
and it almost feels like the economists
are punishing the most financially
vulnerable in our society hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time